joe derosa does such a good impression
of you when i do you it just
it's not good
i hope i don't sound like this
that's your essence i think that's
probably what i sound like if you're uh
like on the other side of the wall maybe
i don't know
you're right yeah we've never taken a
break in the middle of a gas station i
know i had all this momentum going on i
got to start all over again
go ahead go to the card
see this
we won game one
here comes the second of the double
header
there is something i wanted to talk to
you about which was uh conspiracies i i
love conspiracies and you love
conspiracies mainstream ones
i don't go down the rabbit hole
you know uh you know that you know
people are aliens
and that there's a sh you know
shape-shifting yeah yeah i don't know
i don't get into that i would look into
that
do you oh you get into this i enjoy it
it's a fun way to stay uninvolved with
politics
you're like what's the difference
they're all shape-shifting lizard people
eating babies you know what i mean no
that's the way you tap out when you
haven't read about something you try to
act like you know about the issue yeah
somebody brings up something you can't
you know that's the deafness i mean
they're just they're all a bunch of
lion sons of [ __ ] that's how i do
with sports they're like who do you
think i just ah who cares it's all money
i saw that brad pitt movie i was hoping
you're gonna ask
i was hoping you're gonna ask if you had
on here the uh the richie incognito
thing with that that's that guy who it
sounds like a spy
i know that's like a great wrestling
name isn't it yeah like a manager
um yeah he he like he's like a 300 pound
dude and he's bullying another 300-pound
dude oh i did hear about that i don't
understand now you know what is about
that whole thing i don't think it's any
of my business
you know what i mean that was a private
phone call
you know and then you put it on tv dude
if you took 90 of my my text messages
and phone messages and you put them on
the news you would run out of podiums to
put in front of me that i would have to
apologize the crap me and derosa say to
each other forget it
our stuff is so bad we actually have
code
you know what's crazy is i knew that
yeah i'm closing up with joe where he's
like look at the fake name yeah yeah
yeah
how look at everybody here getting
silent like you don't do the same thing
you know
i do know
everybody has yeah you got your little
paula deen moments you got something
you know everybody coming down on that
chef like they're a perfect person
i i miss the days when a paula dean a
paula deen moment was when you put a pie
on a windowsill to cool
it was a simpler time